THE CAMPAIGN.
SHE WILL BE VISITING THE HOUSE
PERMANENT SELECT COMMITTEE ON
INTELLIGENCE TOMORROW.
>> Bret: WARNED THAT WITH
CARROTS AND INHERITED LATER.
ONE OF THE SURVIVORS FROM A
FLORIDA MASSACRE CREDITING THE
LAW FROM EVERYONE AROUND HER FOR
HER RECOVERY.
SHE SPOKE TO REPORTERS TODAY.
>> I WAS THINKING ABOUT THE
LETTERS AND GIFTS EVERYONE HAS
GIVEN AND ALL THE LOVE THAT'S
BEEN PASSED AROUND.
I DEFINITELY WOULDN'T BE HERE
WITHOUT IT, AND I JUST WANT TO
SEND MY APPRECIATION AND LOVE
OUT TO ALL OF YOU.
>> Bret: RESCUERS INITIALLY
THOUGHT SHE WAS DEAD.
SHE SUFFERED BULLET WOUNDS TO
HER CHEST, ABDOMEN, AND ARM.
SHE HAS UNDERGONE THREE
SURGERIES.
AS JOHN ROBERTS MENTIONED, THE
MAN WHO BECAME THE FACE OF THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE TO THE
MASSACRE IS NOW HIMSELF FACING
INTENSE SCRUTINY.
CORRESPONDENT PHIL KEATING HAS
THE STORY OF THE BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF TONIGHT FROM PARKLAND.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING.
SHERIFF SCOTT ISRAEL, THE MAN
WHO WALKED UP TO THE CAMERAS ON
EVENING NUMBER ONE, DECLARING
THE HORROR FOR EVERYONE THAT 17
LIVES HAD BEEN TAKEN AT THE
SCHOOL END.
TWO TIMES HE'S BEEN ELECTED AS
THE DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE FOR
SHERIFF.
REELECTED IN 2016 WITH 72% OF
THE VOTE.
HE CALLS THESE DEMANDS FOR HIS
OUSTER PURELY POLITICAL AT A
TIME WHEN THE TEARS HAD NOT YET
STOPPED.
>> I CAN ONLY TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT I KNEW
ABOUT.
I HAVE GIVEN AMAZING LEADERSHIP.
SHERIFF'S GOT ISRAEL SUDDENLY ON
THE DEFENSIVE FOR THE JOB HE IS
DOING AS SHERIFF OF FLORIDA'S
SECOND MOST POPULOUS COUNTY.
MORE THAN 70 STATE LAWMAKERS ALL
REPUBLICAN HAVE CALLED ON
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT
TO SUSPENDED ISRAEL WHO WAS
ELECTED AS A DEMOCRAT, FOR
INCOMPETENCE AND NEGLECT OF DUTY
INCOMPETENCE AND NEGLECT OF DUT
DUTY.
SHERIFF ISRAEL ACKNOWLEDGED HIS
DEPUTIES WERE CALLED OUT NEARLY
TWO DOZEN TIMES TO DEAL WITH A
VOLATILE AND GUN TEST CRUZ BUT
NEVER TOOK IT FURTHER.
THE GOVERNOR HAS ORDERED THE
FLORIDA DEPARTMENT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO INVESTIGATE.
>> THE LOCAL SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT, THEY HAVE TO BE
COMPLETELY TRANSPARENT.
WE HAVE TO DO A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION.
WHOEVER DIDN'T DO THEIR JOB HAS
TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
>> NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
SPOKESPERSON FAULTS THE MAN AT
THE TOP FOR NOT USING HIS
AUTHORITY TO ARREST CRUZ,
ADDING.
>> I WISH AS MUCH ATTENTION
GIVEN TO THE BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF IS TRYING TO BLAME
5 MILLION INNOCENT LAW-ABIDING
GUN OWNERS.
>> THE SHERIFF SHOCKED THE
COMMUNITY WHEN HE SAID HIS ARMED
DEPUTY ASSIGNED TO GUARD THE
HIGH SCHOOL FAILED TO ENTER THE
FRESHMAN BUILDING AS THE BULLETS
WERE FLYING.
>> AT THIS POINT, ONE DEPUTY WAS
REMISS.
DERELICTION OF DUTY.
HE IS NOW NO LONGER WITH THE
AGENCY.
>> THE ATTORNEY PUSHED BACK
SAYING SCOT PETERSON WAS NOT A
COWARD AND EVIDENCE WILL
EXONERATE HIS ACTIONS.
AMID REPORTS THAT UPON ARRIVING
ON SCENE, THREE OTHER DEPUTIES
ALSO TOOK UP POSITIONS BEHIND
CARS INSTEAD OF RUSHING INTO THE
SCHOOL.
THEY SHERIFF SAYS HE'S LOOKING
INTO IT.
SUNDAY SHERIFF ISRAEL SAID HE
WILL ABSOLUTELY NOT RESIGN.
>> YOU DON'T MEASURE A PERSON'S
LEADERSHIP BY A DEPUTY NOT GOING
IN.
>> MORE ON THE RESOURCE OFFICER
VIA HIS ATTORNEY.
HE SAYS THE REASON HE DID NOT
STORM BUILDING 12 ON THE DAY OF
THE SHOOTING WAS AT THE MOMENT